[Music]
on December 1st 1884 the doors of the
Pavilion polychrome were flung open and
a curious public poured into the massive
Hall to see what all the fuss was about
the first exhibition of the society
day's artiste Independence was opening
with a young group of rebellious artists
they were sick and tired of the
establishment rejecting their works for
display at the salon pair's biggest and
most prestigious art show so after years
of complaining they decide to set up
their own Salon their stated goal was to
allow the artists to present their work
to public judgment with complete freedom
parisians like most people loved a
spectacle and Paris in the 1880s was
full of spectacles this was the Bell
Epoch after all a time of incredible
change new technologies new products and
new ideas were everywhere
and now the newspapers and posters were
advertising a new type of art to
experience
one of the biggest and most radical
paintings in the show was the bathers at
as near
nearly 10 feet wide and seven feet tall
it was the first major painting of
George Sora just 25 years old and he'd
been working on it for nearly two years
from a distance one might have mistaken
it as another impressionist painting
impressionism had been causing a stir
for nearly 20 years now artists like
Claude Monet Edward Manet and August
Renoir had been the young rebels of the
1860s and 1870s daring to challenge
painterly conventions with their visible
brush Strokes saturated colors and focus
on feeling and light rather than
classical realism
but there was a lot more going on in
this painting than meets the eye
essentially it's a big science
experiment Syrah has carefully
constructed his picture with highly
disciplined brush Strokes that from a
distance fool our eyes into seeing
colors and tones that aren't actually
there on the canvas and he's using
recent discoveries in color theory to
select contrasting colors to influence
one another
and his choice of subjects and the way
he depicts them was daring a painting of
this size would have traditionally been
reserved for a great battle or
historical event or perhaps a Biblical
scene if it was to hang in a church
yet saradi picks bathers working class
bathers his title States the scene is
set in asnier a dirty industrial suburb
of Paris you can see the factories in
the background
these aren't pitiable Street urchins
though these are regular relatable
people just taking a break
and yet his subjects are totally
Anonymous he's not replacing actors
faces with royalty like Academia did we
can't even see most of the faces so this
painting huge in scale and so
meticulously constructed is a tribute to
ordinary unknown people living in the
suburbs
the critics didn't quite know what to
make of it as one said it is painted
with so much conviction that it appears
almost touching and I don't quite dare
poke fun at it of course plenty did poke
fun and moved on quickly little did they
know that they were looking at the seeds
of the next Global revolution in art
post-impressionism
I'm Ricky Allman I'm a professor of
painting and drawing at the University
of Missouri Kansas City I'm also an
artist
I discovered post-impressionism while an
art school in Boston and was profoundly
influenced by these artists especially
Cezanne growing up in the Rocky
Mountains my mind was constantly
imagining different shapes and patterns
emerging and moving in the Rocks Cliffs
and boulders
when I found out that's exactly what
Cezanne was doing with Monson Victoria I
felt a strange sort of validation and
excitement about my childhood fantasies
it gave me courage and inspiration to
begin painting abstract mountains which
I've been doing for over 20 years now
over the next 24 lessons I want to take
you up close into the world of the
post-impressionists I want to show you
how they experienced the incredible
change happening all around them science
technology politics religion society and
philosophy were all being completely
reimagined
this is exactly what the
post-impressionists would do with
painting I want to talk about what
caused these artists to think and feel
the way they did how it affected their
artwork and of course we'll dig deep
into the content of their paintings to
see how they altered the trajectory of
art forever
modern life is complicated confusing and
difficult to understand one reason we
value art in our lives is because
artists act kind of like a sieve or a
filter sucking in inspiration from all
around them and then channeling that
into a unique Vision an interpretation
of the times right there for us to see
on the canvas or the screen
it helps us make sense of the world
around us art has a unique way to make a
CR World our times and ourselves in a
different way
the post-impressionists wanted to do all
that and they didn't care what rules
they broke while they did it they pushed
the boundaries of Art in every direction
and some of them like Van Gogh Saran
Cezanne have become some of the most
recognizable and significant artists in
Western Art
it's important to realize though that
post-impressionism wasn't a clear-cut
movement with a distinctive Style
if you know a little about your art
history you can usually pick a Rococo
painting from a Renaissance one or a
Cubist painting from pop art
post-impressionism though was much more
fluid and it can be hard to define the
boundaries of the movement in fact the
term post-impressionism didn't even
really get first used until 1910 several
years after what some considered to be
the end of the movement in 1905.
art historians are always trying to put
artists into little boxes and categories
and it was very useful to have this new
term to describe all this change that
had gone on over the past three decades
but it's not a term that the artists
themselves ever used
some considered themselves part of much
smaller movements like the symbolists
Nabi group or the Neo Impressionists
others had ideas that were so different
they didn't really fit with anyone else
most artists probably didn't worry about
it too much and were happy to leave such
questions to the academics
but despite the huge variety there's
several main themes connecting them the
first is color Vivid unnatural colors
many of them only recently possible
through the wonders of modern chemistry
the post-impressionists love color in
all its forms and many as new scientific
discoveries in color theory to guide
their work
so Science and Technology helped the
post-impressionists open up their
palettes
the second is abstraction the
post-impressionists rejected classical
realism and look for new less literal
ways to depict the world or to convey
emotions and feelings
some like Cezanne played around with
angles Optical science and perspective
to represent the world in a totally
different way and open the door to the
later cubis as he did so
others use symbols bold lines blocks of
color patterns or even the physical
qualities of paint itself to represent
their subjects some like
toulouse-lautrec use these new
simplified forms to become early graphic
designers creating artistic posters for
the mass Market
and the third is their interest in
non-western art keep in mind that
African art Asian art and Indigenous art
from all over the world were far more
developed in Europe in terms of
abstraction patterning color theory
symbolism Western Art in the 19th
century was really just discovering what
had been going on elsewhere for
centuries
but in the late 19th century increased
International Communication and the
start of globalization was exposing many
to the art of other places for the first
time many of the post-impressionists
couldn't get enough of it Japanese art
particularly with a huge influence on
many but are from Africa south Asia and
even South America was starting to
filter in and Inspire European artists
to incorporate elements into their own
work
and finally experimentation the
post-impressionists did everything they
told you not to in art school many
post-impressionists were self-taught
with fresh eyes and New Perspectives and
approaches
Syrah in the pointless use tiny dots in
intricate brushwork to construct their
images Van Gogh painted with brush
Strokes so thick and heavy that the
paint nearly fell off the canvas
creating incredible textures and effects
everyone's technique was a bit different
but they were all trying to achieve the
same end forget about the rules and find
new ways to express their own personal
vision
in fact it's their individualism and
unique approaches that makes
post-impressionism so interesting to
study and such a pivotal movement
because they were pioneering artists who
started kicking down the doors of
centuries of convention and setting art
free
they help make art about individual
expression rather than realistic
depiction and as we'll see they really
did Lay the foundations for Modern Art
we're going to cover a lot of ground in
this course and I'll be talking about
both the artists and movements of the
period And also the big changes in the
world that influence their world view
but for the rest of this first lecture
we need to start with impressionism
which all the post-impressionists were
either inspired by or reacted against
the impression is rock the boat and the
post-impressionists broke the boat into
a hundred pieces grab their own boards
and surfed off into the sunset
[Music]